willie garson has died he was 57.
according to reports the actor's death
follows a brief illness and he was
surrounded by family when he died
willie's son nathan shared this tribute
to instagram on tuesday the message said
in part i'm so glad you got to share all
your adventures with me and we're able
to accomplish so much i'm so proud of
you there's so much heat
around the show right now we kind of
feel we were a little nervous this year
because we felt we were
slightly under the radar before
and
we're certainly not under the radar
anymore which is very exciting so we
can't wait many of willy's friends
shared their personal tributes to social
media willie's sex and the city co-star
cynthia nixon wrote so deeply deeply sad
we have lost willy garson we all loved
him and adored working with him he was
endlessly funny on screen and in real
life willie starred in a number of film
and tv roles over the years including
white collar and most famously on the
landmark hbo series
oh my god she's fashion roadkill
willie's performance at stanford made
him a fan favorite character we've been
friends for about 20 years so like
really close friends so this is like we
well we always say that we'd be with
each other we'd be hanging out anyway on
the on each other's set even if we
weren't on the show together so it's
just an extension of our lives together
just playing these kooky characters
though willie was already announced to
be part of the show's revival and just
like that and was spotted filming in new
york city with sarah jessica parker and
mario cantone who said in his tribute on
instagram i couldn't have had a more
brilliant tv partner you are the first
man to accept me
for the man that i actually am the new
season is set to debut in the fall
[Music]
you